[Music]
okay so give people enough time and
enough luxury to think and they'll come
up with any idea possible right and the
possibility that actually reality is
consciousness to put it boldly is a
thought that has been kicking around in
a surprising number of contexts for a
surprisingly long time it's recently got
a certain sort of revival in that most
inhospitable of institutional contexts
the American University analytic
philosophy departments but in fact even
in the West this idea has been there for
a long time the idea that somehow
reality is consciousness now I'm going
to make a basic distinction that works
pretty much as much in the history of
modern Western philosophy since the 17th
18th century as it did in classical
India and there are sort of blurring
edges between these two ideas one might
broadly be called idealism and the other
is panned psychism about which I'm going
to be talking today under idealism I'm I
mean by idealism the claim that the
world is in fact part of the
consciousness of a subject considering
it that in some sense you can collapse
what seems other to the conscious
subject into the contents of that
subjects
states of awareness on the other hand
hand psychism although as I said it
bleeds in to idealism by psychism says
that when we analyze oh we have to come
to the best explanation possible for
what this dazzling reality is it turns
out to be something strikingly different
from what it appears to be which is it
is not a reality that is present to
something other than it namely the
subject of awareness who is
contemplating it but rather that there
is one single kind of truth
that would explain in its own existence
both the world as it is found and that
which finds it now the broad category
under which this view Falls might be
called monism so there are many
different kinds of mollisons
but the most dominant monism the one
which is perhaps the most pervasive
today and not only in philosophy but is
sort of taken for granted as part of
everything from computing and robotics
through the social sciences and possibly
into the sciences is a kind of what
might be called a materialist Morrison
so what that says is that it might seem
that there is this mysterious situation
in which an inert world is contemplated
by and is experienced by something that
is not of it that
by which it is possible to even
contemplate the textured feature sort of
quality of subjectivity or consciousness
it might only it only seems that way
because actually if you pursue the
analysis of what makes up this reality
far enough you're finally going to come
to the stage where this consciousness
that seems different from the world
which it contemplates turns out in fact
to be part of that material world itself
so there is some level at which there is
an explanation of philosophical
explanation for consciousness in terms
of what seems non conscious this world
the trees the stars and so forth so
that's the kind of materialist monism
there is only one thing and that
developed in different traditions at
different times but particularly in
modern Western thought as a reaction to
what might be called a dualism which is
that there are two categories of being
one that is the material does not have
any kind of reflexivity to it and the
consciousness or the subjectivity that
contemplates it so they're two different
things most famously of course
articulated by Rene Descartes as dualism
of mind and body so it was against this
idea that that was this mysterious other
thing that somehow exists in the world
but does not offer it that monist
materialism has sought to block and
overcome and psychism switches it around
and says what seems to be actually not
this subjectivity this consciousness
this capacity to be aware of that is to
be assimilated into that which seems in
that that which seems like it does not
have a perspective back rather that
world is no different at some
fundamental level than the consciousness
which contemplates it that is actually a
fundamental reality which is the same
soap and psychism is also a mana 'some
it's also trying to say there is only
one explanation one principle that
explains everything I'll turn to some of
the issues that come out of this sort of
contemporary sort of phrasing of pan
sank ism after I have looked at two
classical Indian systems of thought one
of them very ancient which tried which
came up with two from other different
ways of claiming that there is only one
principle that explains everything and
that is somehow to be characterized as
consciousness not non consciousness once
I have kind of given the outlines of
these two systems and I will simplify
terribly because you have hundreds of
texts written over many centuries even
millennia once I have done that I will I
will use that to confront some of the
questions we now face in pants sarcasm
as it is developed in the West one
system called advice' literally means
non-dualism it gives away their
non-dualism says that you must at some
level come to understand that what is
irreducible what is ultimate in the
sense there is no further principle of
explanation is
is consciousness but it takes a very
particular tack in arguing for this
it doesn't actually sort of get its
hands dirty with trying to break up the
Constitution of the world the real world
that becomes present to consciousness it
actually says look the features of our
experience of the world of any subjects
collisions of all the features seem to
suggest this highly infinitely plural
set of entities stretching across time
and space and you might get more
fine-grained descriptions of them
obviously these systems did not know
anything about contemporary signs but
simply in a conceptual way they said you
could analyze these things down to very
fine-grain levels and you might well
find that what you thought was
materially irreducible can be analyzed
through further investigation and the
use of our perception and our reasoning
to smaller kinds of elements but in that
kind of analysis you are in fact never
going to escape the objectivity the non
consciousness of what you encounter
whatever you analyze down to will always
be the object never the subject of the
awareness of it to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit a IDOT TV for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas